so i have two different
three-dimensional figures here i have a
pyramid here on the left and i have a
cone here on the right and we know a few
things about these two figures first of
all they have the exact same height so
this length right over here is h and
this length right over here going from
the peak to the center of the base here
is h as well
we also know that the area of the bases
is the same
so for example in this left pyramid the
area of the base would be x times and
let's just assume that it is a square so
x times x so the area here is going to
be equal to x squared and the area of
the base so that's area
of this base is equal to x squared and
the area of this base right over here
would be equal to area is equal to pi
times
r squared and i'm saying that these two
things are the same so we also know that
x squared is equal to
pi r squared now my question to you is
do these two figures have the same
volume or is it different and if they
are different which one has a larger
volume pause this video and try to think
about that
all right now let's do this together now
given that we're talking about two
figures that have the same height and at
least the area of the base is the same
you might be thinking that cavalry's
principle might be useful and just a
reminder of what that is cavallari's
principle tells us that if you have two
figures and we're thinking in three
dimension three-dimensional version of
cavalry's principle if you have two
figures that have the same height and at
any point along that height the
cross-sectional area is the same then
the figures have the same volume so what
we need to do is figure out is it true
that at any point in this height do
these figures have the same
cross-sectional area
well to do to think about that let's
pick an arbitrary point along this
height and just for simplicity let's
pick halfway along the height although
we could do this analysis at any point
along the height so
halfway along the height there halfway
along the height there so this
distance right over here that would be h
over two
this distance right over here
would be
h over two this whole thing is h
and what we can do is construct
what
look like similar triangles and we can
even prove it to ourselves
that these are similar triangles so let
me construct them
right over here
and the reason why we know they're
similar is that this line is going to be
parallel to this line and that this line
is parallel to that line to that radius
and how do we know that well we're
taking cross sectional areas
that are parallel to the base that are
parallel to the surface on which it sits
in this situation
so in either case
these these cross sections are going to
be parallel so these lines which sit in
these cross sections or sit on the base
and sit in the cross section have to be
parallel as well well because these are
parallel lines this angle is congruent
to that angle
this angle is congruent to this angle
because these are transversals across
parallel lines and these are just
corresponding angles and of course they
share this angle in common and here you
see very clearly right angle right angle
this angle is congruent to that angle
and then both triangles share that and
so the smaller triangle in either case
is similar to the larger triangle and
what that helps us realize is that the
ratio between corresponding sides is
going to be the same so if this side is
h over 2 and the entire height is h so
this is half of the entire height that
tells us that this side is going to be
half of r so this right over here is
going to be r over 2.
and this side over here by the same
argument is going to be x
over 2. and so what's the
cross-sectional area here
well it's going to be x over 2 squared
so it's going to be x over 2 squared
which is equal to x squared over 4 which
is 1 4 of the bases area which is equal
to 1 4 of the bases area and what about
over here well this cross sectional area
is going to be
pi
times r over 2 squared which is the same
thing as pi r squared over 4 or we could
say that is 1 4 pi r squared which is
the same thing as 1 4 of the area of the
base the area of the base is pi r
squared now we're saying 1 4 pi r
squared so this is going to be equal to
1 4 the area and we already said that
these areas are the same and so we've
just seen that the cross sectional area
at that point of the height of both of
these figures is the same and you could
do that one-fourth along the height
three-fourths along the height you're
going to get the same exact analysis
you're going to have two similar
triangles and you're going to see that
you have the same areas same
cross-sectional areas at that point of
the height and so therefore we see by
cavalieri's principles in principle in
three dimensions that these two figures
have the same volume
and what's interesting about that is it
allows us to take the formula which
we've proven and gotten the intuition
for in other videos for the volume of a
pyramid we've learned that the volume of
a pyramid is equal to one-third times
base times height and say well this one
must have the exact same volume it must
also be volumes equal to one-third times
the area of the base
times the height
because in both in both of these cases
the area of the base is the same and the
height is the same and we know that they
have the same volume